[Musique]
notre invité ce matin françois bayrou
nouveau ministre de la justice garde des
sceaux françois bayrou bonjour merci
d'être avec nous l'attentât de le
dernier attentat de londres un français
morts huit blessés deux disparus si vous
avez des informations sur ces deux
français disparus dont je n'en ai pas
j'en ai 20 ans comme tout le monde
oui des bruits ou des rumeurs de
personnes qui ce qui aurait plongé dans
le fouet oui mais je n'en sais
absolument vous ne savez rien d'ailleurs
le gouvernement n'en sais rien et le
gouvernement n'en sais rien de plus mais
moi je lis ce que vous écrivez ce que
tout le mot a été écrit ou dit mais bon
c'est vrai que deux personnes qui
disparaissent comme ça des écrans ces
extraits c'est une question très très
lourde noyau très lourde qui s'explique
aussi par la panique qui saisit les
groupes par exemple dans ce peuple quand
le l'impensable
violence et over ce produit combien de
détenus pour terrorisme en france
actuellement dans nos prisons est-ce que
vous avez des chiffres non je peux pas
vous répondre je vais pas me répondrait
pas les bras vérifiez le chiffre bien
emmanuel macron dans sa campagne proposé
l'ouverture de centres fermés
spécifiquement dédié qui recevraient des
radicaliser c'est toujours l'objectif
c'est l'objectif
en tout cas c'est une nécessité
ou on est obligé de traiter n'est ce pas
il faut voir que les procédures
actuelles ou évitent de déradicalisation
pas seulement en france
nous aurions tous les pays européens et
j'allais dire dans tous les pays du
monde
parce que les états unis sont eux elle
eux aussi placés devant la difficulté de
cet ordre n'apporte pas les résultats
qu'on attendrait le travail qu'il faut
faire qui est très lourd qui est
psychologique qui est de sécurité qui
est de renseignement ce travail là il
est en train d'être bâti on a fait des
progrès sur le renseignement
pénitentiaire en particulier le
gouvernement précédent la lancée c'est
en train de se mettre en place et j'ai
parlé avec les services de
renseignements de ce point ils pensent
que ça progresse que c'est sur la bonne
voie faut aller plus loin
oui il faut aller plus loin dans
j'allais dire l'intervention de
traitement le comment on peut dire le la
la reprise de personnalités qui sont
complètement à la dérive qui sont
parties complètement et dans une dans
une idéologie de violence et
d'extrémisme
est ce qu'une société comme la nôtre a
les réponses pour l'instant il me semble
qu'elle ne les a pas vraiment nous
n'avons pas les réponses
nous ne les avons pas et vous avez
observé naturellement parce que c'est
votre métier
oui le parcours d'un très grand nombre
de ceux qui commettent ces horreurs
passe souvent par la prison et c'est
souvent en prison où il était entré
comme voyous
ils sortent comme radicaliser en
quelques semaines est là et la rapidité
de cette transition là est une question
pour la justice c'est d'ailleurs une
question pour les citoyens évitez de
question pour chacun d'entre nous en
place ces centres fermés aussi qu'ils
recevraient des radicaliser pour éviter
pour éviter qu'ils ne soient au contact
avec d'autres il y à notre point aussi
pardon mais sans cesse t surveillants de
prison nous alertent vous le savez les
portables en prison
les portables en présent aujourd'hui il
y à des détenus qui envoient des vidéos
se moquant des surveillants de prison
qui fondent et facetime avec l'extérieur
des portables qu'on lance par dessus les
murs voilà paraît aujourd'hui la mine y
est la miniaturisation et l ouïe que
évidemment tout le temps et les
surveillants le disent et les aussi les
organisations de surveillance en oeuvre
et elles ont raison de le faire
ce sentiment que on n'arrive pas empêché
on a mis des filets au dessus qu'est-ce
que mais les portables sont tellement
petit aujourd'hui au miniaturisés qu'il
arrive que ça passe on pourrait troubler
tous les signaux ou et où sa demande
abbas laisse les mets au toit kg moi je
suis favorable au travail qu'on doit
faire pour garantir
oui les surveillants et les personnels
de prison contre ce genre de dérapages
la rouille
qu'est ce qu'on fait en bruit les ondes
on doit pouvoir faire ça mais ça pose
des questions qui sont des questions
techniques difficiles et lourdes
auxquelles je vais faire tout ce que je
peux pour apporter une région sera le
vis encore travailler puisque vous êtes
garde des sceaux depuis deux semaines
c'est le cas françois bayrou et j'ai
bien compris et qu'on a travaillé sur
d'autres sujets bon mais je vais y
revenir maintien de l'état d'urgence en
france oui pour l'instant oui pour
l'instant jusqu'au mois de novembre avec
l'idée que
l'état d'urgence est une situation
d'exception
oui donc il faut naturellement quand on
est un gouvernement équilibré visait à
sortir de l'état d'exception pour un an
pour entrer dans un état de la loi et
des pratiques où on se défend
naturellement et donc ça pose des
questions sur les assignations à
résidence
ça pose des questions sur les
interceptions et toutes ces questions là
on va y apporter des réponses pour qu'
on puisse avoir en france un état de la
loi qui garantisse aux citoyens la
sécurité à laquelle ils ont droit
le kata voyait oui je reprends en moins
une dent en une phrase on ne peut pas
laisser lorsqu'on est dans une situation
où on ne peut pas défendre les citoyens
on ne peut pas laisser la situation en
l'état le le premier droit de l'homme
et comme vous savez c'est un sujet
auquel je suis sensible le premier droit
de l'homme c'est la sécurité
le premier droit de l'homme c'est le
droit de sortir de chez soi sans avoir
peur de que c'est que sa famille soit
protégée et donc pour moi en tout cas je
pense que tout ce qui doit être fait
pour protéger les citoyens eux mêmes
soit l'être ou est ce en respectant une
règle simple à laquelle on va arriver à
laquelle je crois qui est chaque fois
qu'il doit y avoir atteinte aux libertés
il faut l'intervention d'un magistrat et
parce que c'est le juge qui dit oui là
et implication en assène la menace est
suffisamment grave pour conférer
l'application de la peine et
l'application de la peine avec un vous
savez qu'aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de
peine qui ne sont pas exécutées exacte
avec d'ailleurs des
il me semble que la question de
l'application des peines doit être prise
en main de manière plus efficace à venir
aussi pour les places de prison puisque
très souvent les peines sont des peines
d'emprisonnement que les places de
prisons sont une question et que le le
le
l'organisation de la prison est aussi
une question vous garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice il n'y aura plus
d'automaticité de l'examen de
l'aménagement de peine
alors vous savez il s'est passé quelque
chose de très devrait enfin une question
on a relevé voyous les ministres
précédents
oui le seuil de peine à partir duquel on
augmente on aménage obligatoirement cui
environ l'a relevé de 6 mois à 2 ans oui
qu'est ce qui s'est passé les magistrats
ont prononcé des peines supérieures à 2
ans chaque fois qu'il voulait que la
personne aille en prison il ya donc une
une question très très sensible et à
laquelle ces questions des peines
il faut que nous apportions une réponse
qui veuille dire quelque chose
vous avez la brouille réponse oui je
vais la porte et quand je vais vous dire
vers une nouvelle loi jeu de nouveaux
textes je vais vous dire je ne
laisserait aucune question en suspens le
la société française et la démocratie
française et le pouvoir en france
il se trouve dans une situation où on a
des centaines de questions qu'on ne
résout jamais on a des au nahd est un
passe partout on a partout 1-1 pouvoir
qui devient impuissant à résoudre les
questions pour moi en tout cas je ne
suis là que pour une seule chose pour
montrer qu'on peut résoudre les
questions une à une gelée fait en
proposant une loi de moralisation qui
traînait depuis les venir depuis
longtemps je le ferai sur chacune des
questions qui se posent et je le ferai
jean jacques bourdin je le ferai
concrètement pas en tout cas c'est le
but que je me fixe pas avec des mots qui
sont des mots abstraits compliqué mais
avec des dés
cision qui entre dans le concret de la
vie de la société française seront
appliquées c'est bien compris françois
bayrou le qatar on reparle du terrorisme
mise en quarantaine par les pays du
golfe
est-ce qu'il faut revenir sur
l'exemption fiscale dont bénéficient le
qatar alors peut-être on peut expliquer
à ceux qui nous écoutent de quoi il
s'agit oui sous un gouvernement
antérieur antérieures sous là sous la
responsabilité de nicolas sarkozy oui le
la république française avait donné au
qatar un avantage fiscal
incroyable qui était qu'il n'était plus
je le fais à grands traits que lui
n'avait pas à assumer d'impôt sur les
plus-values immobilières venant de ces
investissements exhale le seul
contribuable en france identifier qui
n'avait pas à payer des plus values sur
les investissements c'était le qatar est
ce que si tu es ce que cette situation
peut durer je ne le crois pas je pense
qu'il est très important qu'on est en
france une cet exemple équité fiscale
alors gouvernance n est pas ma
responsabilité ministérielle mais moins
comme citoyen comme responsables
politiques et le président de la
république pendant sa campagne a dit
exact que c'était une situation qu'il
fallait le trouver du rayon voilà bien
un projet de loi pour la confiance dans
notre vie démocratique donc premier
texte soumis aux parlements dans
quelques semaines quand le premier texte
soumis au parlement parlement ça veut
dire députés sénateurs réunis non non
non non parlement ça veut dire a semblé
impressionné d'abord sénat ont de suite
congrès congrès lorsqu'il s'agit de
modifier la constitution a justement il
faudra la modifier sur un certain nombre
de points que j'ai signalé la cour de
justice de la république
voilà cette incroyable privilège qui
était depuis des décennies se garantit
aux ministres en disant si vous faites
une bêtise dans l'exercice de votre
mandat ou une faute plus encore des
lions
même un crime dans l'exercice de votre
mandat alors vous ne serez pas jugés par
des juges normaux vous serez jugés par
vos pairs par vos pairs parlementaire
ceci est une survivance qui pour moi
était inacceptable
alors il donc dans ce premier texte il y
aura cela il n'y aura aussi la fin de la
présence des anciens présidents de la
république au conseil constitutionnel
l'interdiction pour les élus d'exercer
trois mandats identique et et successifs
je parle des grands élus je ne parle pas
des petits maires on est bien d'accord
pas de souci petit par l'addition d'un
petit mais ils sont made de la coopec
commune moi j'apprends à la pas la
taille de la commune est
démographiquement donc congrès on est
bien d'accord quand congrès ou
référendum ou référendum le président de
la république lorsque le gouvernement et
lui choisissent de modifier la
constitution à deux armes entre les
mains oui soit il fait voter le texte
par l'assemblée nationale et par le
sénat qu'on réunit ensuite tous ensemble
en congrès et là il faut obtenir la
majorité des trois cinquièmes s'il la
majorité des trois cinquièmes n'est pas
obtenue alors il lui reste la ressource
de faire appel au peuple et c'est le
peuple qui tranche le président de la
république n'hésitera pas et pour moi en
tout cas ils 2e il n'y aura aucune
hésitation si sur des textes essentiels
ou et qui touchent à l'organisation de
notre vie publique
au point que la constitution doit s'en
occuper
s'il y a blow cage il faudra que les
français tranche laisser se nomme et
c'est ce que emmanuel macron a dit tout
au long de sa campagne électorale
et c'est un engagement qu'il prend très
au sérieux parce que ce que je crois
d'historique qui est en train de se
jouer c'est pas seulement un
renouvellement profond du personnel
politique comme on dit des élus des élus
à l'assemblée nationale en particulier
et vous voyez bien ce qui se prépare que
mouvement dans l'opinion sait aussi que
on ne va pas en rester aux situations de
blocage
on va trouver mettre en place imposé par
notre volonté une pratique politique qui
fasse effectivement changer les choses
or le sujet dont nous traitons la la
moralisation de la vie publique la
confiance à retrouver un sujet qui coûte
pas un centime
il fait même faire des économies bon
c'est un sujet qui impose simplement que
la volonté l'emportent sur bon d
habitude ou des privilèges sans que rien
n'y a rien dans votre texte n'y a rien
sur l'indépendance des magistrats du
parquet rassurez vous tout cela vient ça
sera d'ailleurs probablement le même
texte que ce que nous avons évoqué sur
la cour de justice de la république
parce que nous sommes engagés oui je
pense que ça sera le même texte contenu
dans le même temps quand il s'agira
d'études deux d'en venir à la lampe à la
modification de la constitution
on va pas faire plusieurs débats
constitutionnels
on en fera un seul probablement à
l'automne j'imagine à l'automne fun que
ce qui nommera les procureurs joue qui
nommera les procurer via je vous promets
que de ce point de vue là il y aura des
avancées vous avez vous voyez bien vous
voyez aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est blindé le gouvernement
qui nomme les peaux corps après avait
avec le csm qui donne son rôle et que ça
va changer vous savez bien qu'on a
changé qu'on a fait voter un texte
oui et puis le texte n'a jamais été
repris n'est jamais arrivée au congrès
jabour dire que au fond ces deux
autorités le gouvernement aux côtés qui
est élu par les français qui porte ce
qu'on appelle la politique pénale c'est
comment lutte contre ces dérives ces
délits ces crimes
dondon dont une société ne peut pas
accepter la précieuse 1 le gouvernement
avec la politique pédales et de l'autre
le conseil supérieur de la magistrature
qui représente la magistrature dans son
ensemble est un certain nombre de
regards extérieurs sur la magistrature
une autorité
autrement dit plus plus intime dans
l'horreur des magistrats les deux
doivent s'entendre pour nommer les
procureurs et 7
ça fait huit ans où il n'y a pas eu une
nomination en aide à contre l'avion du
conseil je vais perdre là bas
parce que je pense qu'on peut aller plus
loin bon c'est le gouvernement nommera
plus l'échangé
je vous promets que je viendrai vous
voir vous vous expliquer l'idée que j'ai
et qui est je crois enfin que j'ai la
faiblesse de croire intéressante et le
gouvernement n'aura plus le procureur le
gouvernement et le conseil supérieur de
la magistrature devront s'entendre pour
nommer les procureurs le gouvernement ne
nommera plus seuls les probablement mois
ce qui est un pas vers l'indépendance
oui il ya même tout une question sur le
sur le fait très important on peut ben
c'est très important parce que essentiel
il n'existe pas de discussions dans
l'espace juridique européen qui ne
souligne que la france doit faire un pas
vers cette indépendance et c'est
profondément ce que je crois parce que
les procureurs sont des magistrats qui
ont ou qui jugent des poursuites qu'il
faut conduire et qui ont autorité sur l'
enquête judiciaire à 6 puisque nous
parlons de poursuites
une perquisition a eu lieu je la prends
ce matin c'est le télégramme qui donne
l'information a eu lieu jeudi dernier au
siège dé mutuel de bretagne le jour même
de l'ouverture d'une enquête
préliminaire visant d'éventuelles
infractions dans le dossier richard
ferrand une longue perquisition du siège
social des mutuelles de bretelles vous
dites là fait référence est une affaire
qui alourdit la campagne cet hiver
servent que évidemment oui de 7,1 c'est
un événement qui est un événement qui
qui est mou dont se serait passé tous
ceux qui sont présents à ses positions
et le gouvernement même haussier est en
marche pour une pour une raison très
précise c'est que le lit des deux de ce
changement des pratiques dans la vie
publique a été uni des piliers de la
campagne des manuels macron et je puis
vous assurer une chose c'est qu'il y
tient absolument tueuse j'atteste qu'il
y tient absolument est donc évidemment
mais il se trouve que je suis
gardez ce jeu c'est vous le savez il ya
une loi qui a été votée en 2013 et qui
dit une chose très simple dans les
affaires judiciaires
le garde des sceaux n'a pas le droit
d'intervenir
oui mais ne devrait-il pas quitter ses
fonctions de ministre afin de restaurer
la confiance dans la vie démocratique en
françois bayrou la composition du
gouvernement vous me posez des questions
dont vous et c'est toutes les réponses à
l'avance dont la composition est
réellement si vous êtes un observateur
trop attentif la composition du
gouvernement elle dépend du premier
ministre du président de la république
non il est chassé le président dela vous
n'auriez pas choisir et s'avérant str
qui tranche de cette question rires et
je ne veux pas du tout amer jeu des
affaires personnelles de tout ça le
enfin avec votre loi avec san remo avoir
lu à richard ferrand ne serait ni
ministre ni candidats en tout cas ce que
ce qui lui est reproché
sans que je sache c'est vrai oui je n'ai
optionnellement on est d'accord que ce
que j'ai lu dans le journal comme vous
oui parce que le ministre de la justice
se tient à l'écart de l'enez bien
d'accord mais avec la loi
ça n'aurait pas pu se produire sur
plusieurs ou le décharger sur plusieurs
flambées se produisent avec la loi oui
ça n'aurait pas plus ça n'aurait pas pu
se produire
cette loi elle est faite pour mettre des
garde-fous des garde-fous ça veut dire
qu'il peut y avoir des gens qui
conduisent trop vite ou qui dérape où il
lui est arrivé il ya des gars de fait ce
qui lui arrive le bord de la route et ma
responsabilité c'est que les garde-fous
inspire confiance aux français parce que
le but à atteindre et c'est un but que
vous le savez je poursuis pour ma part
depuis très longtemps c'est que ça
redevienne nous re devenir un pays dont
la démocratie soit honnêteté c'est un
voyage aller traîner non mais je vois
bien ce que vous voulez me faire
contrôler bien que je n'ai pas
l'intention en très bien rentrer dans ce
jeu je comprends très bien vous voulez
vous voulez donner confiance aux
citoyens oui mais vous donner confiance
aux citoyens avec un boulet que vous
mais non parce que le l'enquète est en
cours venait de signaler
oui un événement qu'est assez un
important est peut-être en d'autres
temps ça n'aurait pas pu se produire ce
que vous avez indiquée donc à part
qu'ils l'indépendance de la magistrature
et le la loi que nous suivons et le
principe que je suis vous voulez que je
vous dise pourquoi en une phrase aller
pourquoi l'indépendance est aussi
importante parce que l'indépendance des
magistrats
le fait qu'il ne puisse y avoir aucune
pression sur eux garantis que tout le
monde est égal devant la justice les
puissants et ceux qui n'ont aucune
plongée comme disait la fontaine selon
que vous serez puissant ou misérable et
bien je veux que je veux non seulement
je veux je suis engagé à ce que
l'indépendance de la justice garantis
sous cette équipe est là sur le plan
purement politique sera ma dernière
question marielle de sarnez est
candidate à paris si elle est battue
elle ne sera plus ministre c'est la
réalité mais si vous regardez les
enquêtes d'opinion qui paraissent vous
voyez que non seulement elle n'est pas
sur le point d'être battus mais qu'elle
a le soutien dans une circonscription
très difficile un soutien très
majoritaire en tout cas dans les
intentions et qu'elles le méritent
merci et françois bayrou 8h57